you ever see somebody eat something so
good that they turn into a shaman I'm
just curious as it is gonna taste salty
I guess I'm completing the authenticity
of my blackness today we're not bad but
it's not like super flavorful either it
was good though
I mean not too not too much seasoning
going on not bland it's like right in
the middle tastes soulful I'm sorry I
miss him so much I don't ham a lot but
when I get it I'm like okay I'm I miss
you friends this is really good we got
some more I take off this smells great
it looks great like melted right and
when I got it hit my tongue so huh yeah
that's that's a good sign something
really good you know collar to take so
damn long to like rinse oh and you got a
clean collards right usually colored
collards even when given the the scraps
like black people know how to make a
doll out of 50 cents
oh like a bottle yeah
it's a forward yeah good luck on the
feet no yeah sucky that's the way you so
food oh I'm not feeling so I like it
this looks so good this is like a black
person's like couple noodles in you in
college yeah Greece yeah
oh no you're all right mmm sugar on
grants by itself i do salt me butter not
sugar that's disgusting
he cream of wheat you crazy people
yo it's warm
Wow then it reminds me of a toaster
strudel I mean this is ten times better
than that but like hell yeah this is
only dish if you put out that I feel
compelled to finish sweating
I guess she's sweaty I was getting like
feeling like a hot hot flashes whoever's
mama made this little you got a daughter
definitely important this reminds me of
like my family and like yeah like I
might make a phone call after this maybe
when you're able to keep somebody's food
that you know they've you know put love
into so it's kind of like a way to get
your communication sure food is good and
it's amazing this is that feel like the
how Big Mama guidance offal that got a
foot cut off too soon okay my you lost
your foot Oh burn uh no I did